you know an eighth grade girl just uh
bashed a school board over this over the
transgender policy because she said this
is harmful to women
specifically because now we have to to
change with boys
in the locker room two years ago i was
told policy 1040 was just an umbrella
philosophy and you weren't going to
allow boys into the girls locker rooms
but here you are doing just that
everyone knows what a boy is even you
your proposed policies are dangerous and
rooted in sexism
when woke kids asked me if i was a
lesbian or a trans boy because i cut my
hair
short it should tell you these modern
identities are superficial
my guidance counselor's response to my
concerns about bathroom privacy and
safety was
well there are stalls in the bathrooms
now boys are reading erotica in the
classrooms next to girls
and you want to give them access to
girls locker rooms and you want to force
girls to call those boys she you do this
in the name of inclusivity while
ignoring the girls who will pay the
price
your policies choose boys wants over
girls needs
so totally right great stuff uh she's
very you know i i hesitate from playing
you know these viral clips of children
and teenagers because i think
generally speaking i i don't care what
children and teenagers have to say
because by definition they're not
particularly wise or educated um this
however because it was at a political
event it was at a school board meeting
and and she happened to be right on the
issue
then i think it's worth playing uh
however
it goes further than that so much of
this trans issue
is being argued on the right as a matter
of the rights of women you know the
women are losing their bathrooms they're
losing their locker rooms and now little
girls have to change in front of grown
men just because husky hank decided to
call himself helen last week
that that is insane and it's a good
place to begin
but that's not really the argument
really the the problem here is not that
one group's rights are being infringed
by another group's rights
it's not that well yes men have the
right to pretend that they're women in
the privacy of their own mind but not
in the locker room or whatever the issue
is the reality
it is simply the case
that men who put on dresses or not women
hey i am so pleased that you have
enjoyed this content you've watched it
through to the end you want more but
you're not getting more
because you haven't rung the bell you
got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe you got to like it you got to
get the notifications then i would
suggest maybe head on over
to apple podcast google play stitcher
spotify myspace xanga
anywhere you got the michael knowles
show audio podcast and while you're at
it
you can pre-order my upcoming books
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now
only for a few more days thank you we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you